[Music]
how do you think of death given
all that we're talking about and
sort of the first order second order
third order implications of all that
how do you think about death
so physicalism has a very clear
implication for death
if space time is fundamental
and
elementary particles like electrons and
quarks and protons and so forth are the
fundamental nature of reality and what
you are
what your body is is just an assemblage
a complex assemblage of particles
and your consciousness
is somehow an emergent property of
certain activities of those particles
say brain activity
then it's very very clear that
that
in death when the brain dissolves your
consciousness dissolves and that's the
end of the story that's that's the end
that's it
that's a very very clear implication of
physicalism
we can talk about pan psychism
but but physicalism strict physicalism
that's that's the end of the story
if consciousness is fundamental and
space-time is just an interface
and our bodies are merely icons that we
use to represent
certain assembly interactions of
conscious agents and we can go into how
i think about that then
on that approach
there is the possibility
that some aspect of
my consciousness
survives death
now
there i have to look at you know the
mathematics of the model and and
go into it but
it may be for example that
the bear awareness
that's associated with me just awareness
without content that that survives
but all the
details of donald hoffman and his life
story within this interface maybe that
all dissolves maybe we can and that
that's a story about what is
consciousness up to we can talk about
what is you know if consciousness is
fundamental what is it doing and why
what what what is the dynamics of
consciousness about
and we we really to answer the question
about death we might have to answer that
question too
it's a big one
please continue
[Laughter]
so i'll try a stab at that question
because i think it relates to the death
question
so what is consciousness doing and why
you know the the right answer is i don't
know and i've only seen one idea
that seems deep enough to at least be
worth
thinking about i'm not saying it's the
right idea but the only one idea that
seems deep enough to at least be a
candidate and it again comes from
girdles and completeness theorem
girdle says that
essentially
no matter how much you explore within a
particular conceptual system
there's
you can't get all the truth there's
there's always going to be more to
explore
mathematically
so if consciousness is the fundamental
nature of reality and consciousness is
all there is then mathematical structure
is only about the possibilities of
consciousness
that's all that there is to be about
and so
what if
what consciousness is doing since the
exploration of mathematical structure is
in principle
unending
then
perhaps the exploration of the
possibilities of consciousness itself is
in principle unending
and therefore
consciousness
what is up to is
exploring all of his potentialities
and the reason is continuing to do that
from our perspective is continue to do
that is because there's no end to it in
principle
so consciousness itself is in some sense
always learning about itself
and so
perhaps then what we are
what you what people are and what cats
are and what dogs are and what amoebas
are and so forth is consciousness
trying on different headsets
different realities
and exploring
and
and losing itself i mean so this very
interesting idea that consciousness
chooses to really explore so deeply that
it loses itself in the exploration
doesn't even know what it is
it becomes a physicalist
it actually thinks that consciousness
isn't fundamental it goes through the
whole bit and then slowly has to wake up
and and so doing it really explores what
it's not
and what it is in some sense to know
what you are you have to know what
you're not
and so
so on that point of view
the hoffman icon
is simply
consciousness
ex taking a perspective on itself
looking at itself through a particular
space-time headset
taking a little projection and from that
headset i there's a finite there was a
birth there was
growing strong until your 20s and 30s
and then after your 40s you start
declining and you know in your 80s and
90s you die
and that whole process is just
consciousness exploring itself from a
particular perspective in which case
maybe
the hoffman
icon and and maybe a lot of stuff can be
left behind but in some sense
consciousness itself
has has learned something through that
experience and the 8 billion other
people and the
quadrillions of amoebas and the who
knows how many viruses and and so forth
consciousness is just trying on
innumerable headsets and when it's done
with that headset it takes it off
and
awareness is
is perfectly fine
the the raw awareness is fine but the
the the detailed icons that happen to
appear space-time icons objects in space
and time brains neurons all those things
those were you know those are just
those were just icons and you know
you studied them and then you realized
pretty cool really you know mount
everest what a beautiful icon
death valley what a beautiful icon these
are really but i'm not that i'm
something even more transcendent than
space and time i'm more transcendent
than death valley and so so
consciousness is just waking up i mean
again i'm trying to tell a story i'm not
saying that it's it's correct but it's
just it's the only story i've seen so
far that at least is deep enough that is
worth taking
seriously
who is the origin of this
this story and
can you ever know that it's accurate do
you think through
testing or experimentation
the story that i'm saying right now has
an interesting
way that you might be able to test it so
this
dynamics of conscious agents as i
mentioned is a markovian dynamics right
you can make it so-called stationary
dynamics in which the entropy of the
dynamics doesn't change
but you can show that even if you have
this markovian dynamics of consciousness
in which the entropy never changes
any
projection
by by conditional probability any
projection
looking at that dynamics
we'll see it as
increasing an entropy
in other words
the arrow of entropy the arrow of time
is an artifact
of the projection
so consciousness itself has no arrow of
time
but you can prove from this mathematics
that you get an arrow of time by
projection the proof is trivial like two
or three lines so here's a project that
i think would be really fun can we show
that when you look at all the different
ways that you could project
consciousness in this mathematics
the conditions under which all these
different arrows of time the entropy
that you get
satisfy
the lorentz transformations in other
words can we get special relativity out
of this we would have to model also the
space aspects of it what's happening to
space
as you know projection of the dynamics
of of these conscious agents but we see
the time aspect so could we actually
show how special relativity arises as
just different perspectives that
consciousness can take
can take on
a fundamental dynamics of consciousness
that's that's that has no arrow of time
that's the kind of thing where we could
start to make brand new predictions that
could be testable
you